could we say that socialism is as
old-fashioned as disco music here in
europe i know many of you will think
this is just one opinion but before you
launch into writing in the comments
section take a look at this rather
depressing map
[Music]
in this map you can see the remaining
social democratic governments in europe
at this time if you notice there are
hardly any countries in red and some of
them like spain have red parties which
are plummeting in polls which means that
it's not just opinion that we have here
at visualpolitik unfortunately it's a
fact social democratic parties have less
and less power every day and some of you
will say let's see grant football and
democracy are like that sometimes you
win and sometimes you lose but the
problem is is there are many countries
in europe where socialist parties are
not even the second political force and
this is a trend that's been going on
since the financial crisis of 2008.
[Music]
i'll give you an example france for
decades france was a two-party country
the main political forces were the
center-right ump and the socialists but
in recent years the political battle has
been between the ultranationalists of
marine le pen and the liberals of macron
the socialists have become
something similar could happen in
germany and what about greece the
passock social democrats are on the
verge of disappearing
[Music]
in other words the problem is not that
the socialists are losing elections the
problem is is that soon they may
disappear altogether again this is not
an opinion this is something very real
that is happening and should be of
concern to those of us on the left and
what are countries that still have
socialist governments what about them
for example denmark yes it is true
denmark has a social democratic
government headed by a woman methi
fredericksdown
no this lady is nothing like what you'd
imagine from a nordic socialist her
immigration policy makes victor orban
look like a tree-hugging heppy she's
even pledged to have zero refugees
that's right put another way socialism
seems to be on the verge of disappearing
and the few remaining socialists are
mutating into things that bear very
little resemblance to the socialism
we've known so far put another way
socialists are having an identity crisis
where there are three tribes fighting
true socialists third way and
post-modernists and it's not at all
clear which one of them will win or if
another new tribe will emerge to try and
get socialism back on track many of you
will ask how is this possible after all
there are more billionaires than ever
before people say that the inequalities
between rich and poor are getting more
and more pronounced i mean for god's
sake jeff bezos has going to space money
so why have so many people in europe
stopped voting for socialist parties
what's happening and is there any way to
resurrect social democracy in europe
today we're going to answer all of these
questions but first let's look at a
little bit of history
[Music]
the first question we have to ask
ourselves is what is the working class
think about it if there's one thing that
defines socialists it's the working
class they're the parties called to
represent the common people now then
what is a worker and how is he or she
defined according to karl marx workers
are those who do not own the means of
production that is to say we could
divide society into two groups the
capitalists who own companies and
factories and the workers who provide
the labor receive salary and do not own
property
[Music]
having made this clarification in just a
few less words than karl marx our
history begins in 1918. that is the year
of the definitive clash between
communists and socialists both had the
same goal to put an end to capitalism
and establish a dictatorship of the
proletariat the difference is is that
the communists did it by the means of a
violent revolution in russia the social
democrats want to achieve it by winning
elections and liberal democracies
passing new laws and making a gradual
transition
as you can imagine the pure marxist said
that the social democrats were deluded
to thinking they could change the system
from within i know left is infighting
that's not a thing right however history
has shown that the social democrats were
right yes it is true the oxidised
marxists had their revolutions in
agricultural countries both russia and
china had their communist revolutions
but in industrial and wealthy europe
that europe was the stronghold of the
social democrats
in 1918 germany was the first country in
the world to have a social democratic
government think about it if politics is
the market the socialists had a perfect
product it was aimed at the majority
group the workers remember this was
1918. almost the entire economy was
based on industry a few capitalists
dominated the enterprises and the rest
were workers workers who were potential
voters of the german social democratic
party this is how the boom of socialism
began
[Music]
after the germans came the nordic
countries sweden norway denmark all of
them were countries with huge industrial
sectors all of them were the perfect
breeding ground for socialist parties to
take over
but wait a moment because this is only
the beginning in 1929 something happened
that triggered the success of social
democracy until it became the dominant
ideology yes you guessed it we are
talking about the crash of 29 the great
collapse of the financial system
at that time the political parties that
defended the free market lost all their
credibility for obvious reasons the
majority of voters switched to voting
for left-wing parties parties that
defended the interests of the workers
from the united states to the nordic
countries all democratic governments
reinvented themselves and if you thought
that the second world war brought this
whole socialist wave to a halt you are
wrong from the 1940s to the 1980s the
entire developed world embraced an
economic system where the state played a
fundamental role in business
this was the era of the birth of the
welfare state kinsey economics high
taxes and large public enterprises the
socialists were red hot okay maybe they
didn't overthrow capitalism but they
were damn sure going to reform it
however everything changed again in the
1970s the social democratic model
collapsed and 10 years later so did the
soviet union suddenly the idea of ending
capitalism slowly or revolutionarily was
no longer attractive so socialists and
communists stopped winning elections but
if you thought this was the end of
socialism in europe you are wrong the
social democrats did not die they simply
evolved
[Music]
this is how the so-called third way was
born the third way was the response by
the left to the fall of pure socialism
and now i know what a lot of you are
thinking the third way wasn't that when
the social democrats totally sold their
soul to capitalism yes that's both what
communists and classical socialists
would say but the truth is that the
third way allowed the socialist parties
to sweep the floor once again in various
elections this was the era of tony blair
in the uk gerhard schroeder in germany
and even zapatero in spain in fact more
or less the 1990s and 2000s were the
golden years of the left in europe these
days however things have changed why
we're going to look at that right now
[Music]
a working class hero is nothing to be if
any of you are affiliated with any
left-wing party you will surely have
heard it a thousand times the problem
with the socialists is that they have
forgotten the working class the question
is who are the working class today if we
go by marx's definition workers are
those who earn a wage and do not own the
means of production by this definition
satyam nagela the ceo of microsoft is
working class and no we've not gone mad
the ceo of any company is a worker who
has paid a salary the salary is set by
the board of shareholders who are the
ones who own the means however no one
can imagine a chief executive joining a
union can they well obviously not the
first thing we have to do is to redefine
the working class
we could say that blue-collar workers
are those who have unskilled jobs that
is people who work in mechanical jobs
that do not require a university degree
until the 1980s this was the majority
throughout europe but today the reality
is very different take a look at this
graph
in this graph you can see how there are
fewer and fewer workers in france we've
used the example of france but we could
use almost any other european country
manufacturing jobs are in danger of
extinction and the new majority working
class all over europe are professionals
that is people who have gone to
university and work in offices they
already account for more than 20 of the
workforce here in europe think about it
almost all industry has left europe for
china and other asian countries and the
new factories are nothing like the
factories of the 20th century
it used to take hundreds of assembly
line workers to produce a car now that
work is done by robots and the workers
who manage those robots are specialized
engineers who've gone to university if
you don't believe me well we're going to
travel to the land of the worker par
excellence france that's right france if
there's one country famous for its
strikes it's protests and it's strong
unions it has to be france but how many
workers are actually members of trade
unions today well we'll take a look at
that here
[Music]
if you'll notice the unions peaked in
the late 1970s from then on they've been
in continual decline now only eight
percent of the french working population
is unionized and france is just one
example i could have shown you a very
similar graph if we were talking about
spain the uk or almost any other
european country the only exception i
have is belgium which maintains union
membership of 50 why well that's a topic
for another video and i know what some
people will say really the working class
has disappeared but that's not possible
there are still a lot of groups living
in marginal situations there are the
rich and then there are the poor and yes
you are right but those poor people are
no longer workers
[Music]
i'll give you an example spain if you're
watching this video from spain you
already know that the spanish economy is
going from bad to worse all the data
shows that there is more and more
inequality between the rich and the poor
but the poor are not the workers they're
the unemployed roughly 40 of young
spaniards are unemployed as you can
imagine if a politician approaches a
young unemployed person to talk about
labor rights the young person would say
oh that would be great if i had a job
but wait a minute because we are not
done this trend started in the early
2000s that was the moment when the
working class started to disappear in
europe but the year when the real
collapse of socialism began was 2008.
[Music]
exactly that was the year of the
financial crisis and many of you at this
point will be thinking how is that
possible the financial crisis was the
collapse of the free market the proof
that neoliberalism has failed the
decline of capitalism wasn't it well
from the electoral standpoint the
opposite phenomenon occurred let me give
you an example greece
the greece social democratic party the
so-called passop was one of the two
major parties in that country to give
you an idea in 2009 they had 43.9 of the
votes six years later in 2015 pasok was
left with only 4.68
of the electorate that's right they
didn't even make it to 5 today in 2021
the numbers are still very similar pasok
has gone from being a governing party to
being a pensioner's club with a lot of
time on his hands so what can the
socialists do to regain the confidence
of voters what can a european do when he
runs out of ideas where can he find
inspiration well pay attention
[Music]
the americans
i know looking to the united states to
copy ideas doesn't seem like the most
anti-capitalist solution in the world
but let's be honest the united states
has the most professionalized politics
in the world campaign consultants in the
united states use polls market research
and databases to run campaigns that
explains why the left wing in this
country was the first to realize that
the working class has changed
[Music]
to give you an idea in 1980 20 of jobs
in the us were an industry in 2016 that
figure was only eight percent in 1979
unions in the united states had 20
million members in 2013 even with a much
larger population there were only 14
million members but wait a minute
because that's not all some might think
that the working class is more likely to
vote for left-wing parties right that's
the basis of this whole video however
for decades opinion polls have been
saying just the opposite
[Music]
if we understand the working class as
people in blue-collar jobs we soon
learned that being blue-collar is a
predictor of voting republican no really
of course we're not saying that all
blue-collar workers vote republican but
what we can say is that the republican
party is the preferred choice in this
group in other words dividing society by
classes is no longer a good strategy for
getting votes at least not if you're a
left-wing politician however there is
another way of dividing society that can
work do you know who does vote mostly
for left-wing parties racial minorities
both hispanic and african-americans are
much more likely to vote democrat and
that is how the so-called identity
politics was born
and that is also how a new ideology
emerged an ideology that is neither
communism nor socialism nor the third
way we are talking about post-modernism
the post-modern left no longer focuses
on material equality but on identity
oriented politics i don't think i need
to explain any further just listen to
the speech of any left-wing politician
in your country and you'll probably
figure out what we're talking about the
problem is what happens when you try to
import these policies into europe well
the main problem is how many people of
african origin are there in europe are
there really that many appraised racial
minorities can we really say that europe
is the same as the united states well
we're going to take a look at that right
now
[Music]
the end of socialism all socialist
parties are engaged in open war at the
moment a battle between the classical
socialists the third way and the
postmodernists in the uk they tried to
go back to their origins that explained
the rise of jeremy corbyn as leader of
the labour party
jeremy corbyn was a return to the
essence of socialism so how did he do in
the elections you may ask well you can
judge for yourselves
general election 2019 worst night for
labor since 1935 bbc 13 december 2019.
we're seeing something very similar in
spain in spain the socialist party
currently governs jointly with pademos
which is an extreme left-wing party for
years spain was the exception to the
rule it seemed the last bastion of
socialism in europe however the polls
are starting to look worse and worse for
the spanish government and you only need
to look at the map to understand that
what we're seeing is very real
and you may be wondering where all the
votes are going that used to go to the
socialist parties part of this answer
can be found in yes another map if you
notice there are not only red and blue
countries we also have dark blue
countries and orange countries the dark
blue ones are the countries with
nationalist right-wing governments the
orange ones are the liberal center these
two ideological currents are becoming
more and more significant in some
countries like france we could say that
they are the new bipartisanship we are
no longer talking about socialists
versus conservatives but nationalists
versus liberals other countries such as
germany are seeing the rise of other
groups such as environmentalists
[Music]
so now the question is over to you are
we really facing the end of socialism
will we see other ideological currents
replace it or will we see a fourth way
that brings socialist parties back to a
new golden era you can leave your answer
in the comments below as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel and hit the
little bell down there so you don't miss
any of our updates if you like this
video like it and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]